Welcome to the Union Rise Firetruck Training with Supermike, Joël and Steph.
We're here today at the firetruck and we're going to learn the best firetruck skills to protect the local region with responsibility, skill and dedication.
The first thing we do today is filling the truck with water.
And where do we fill it?
At the pump house in the valley.
There we have a special connection point to connect the big hose to fill it very quick.
And where does the water come from there?
From the 1 million litre tank on top of the mountain.
And the good news about that is that it's completely electricity free. No pumps, right? It's gravity.
Yeah, there are pumps but it also works without...
So the good news is that if the fire turns away the electric system, may it never happen, we can always have gravity fed water from that tank, right?
Yes, for sure. And also we have the option to suck water with the pump directly from a river or a spring. So no problem. We always get water.
Right.
But for now we train the easy thing to fill it with the water from our own system.
So now we stop the engine again.
Maybe you can go or you can see it on the ground where the sun is shining. There is a button.
Yes.
Under the clutch pedal. When you push it then the engine goes off.
Ah, it just shuts it off, yeah?
And then we make it on the black switch.
Okay.
So then everything is off for now. You see? No brakes. This is important. Look here. Lift it. Brake.
Yes.
No, we have brakes. Okay, now we go outside and fill the truck.
So on the first part here we have all the connections and stuff we need.
Also the fire guns. The big one. Only to use with two people, not alone. And the small one.
Now one can be used alone?
This is the thing we train today.
One person, yeah?
Yes. And then you need the adapter to fill the truck. Follow me.
So we have here four connections on this side.
Yes.
These are only outlets. So on these places we can connect something to let the water outside from the tank.
This on the right side. Easy to see. This is the hose. Not the metal one. It's from rubber. This is the line to fill.
It's the only one, the rubber one.
That is the only one to fill. Or when we suck water from a well or a river, then we use this.
That's like a dropper kind of.
That is like with a dropper. You can suck without nothing because here we have a pump.
And these pumps also can suck the water inside the tank. Not blowing it only out. Also can suck it in.
So just so we can. These four are outlets and this is an inlet.
This is the only inlet. Later I will mark this all so that it's easier to notice.
But when we do it every week and we collect some practice, I think it's easy to use.
So important is always when you work with these materials, they must lock in really tight.
Locking in?
Yeah. So now you see it's okay. When it's like this, it's dangerous because we have a lot of pressure and it cannot explode.
Yes.
So okay. Now then we take these, these holes always is here because we use these holes for filling.
Now we connect this. Then we must make it on a straight way. Like this.
Okay. And now next step, open this tap. So now it's open. Now we can go to the point here.
Here we have the big wheel with the open and closed sign. When we do it like this, we open.
First slowly a little bit to fill the, the holes. And then.
And now you can listen. So now we go back to the truck.
And you can see here in the middle, there is a transparent hose where we can see the level from the tank.
Now you can see here. You see how it moves.
Yep.
And so you can see how it fills.
So maybe Steph, you can go on the vent here, there.
So now we wait, but it goes very quick. So it's not full power now. It's only to show.
So full power is even quicker.
It's more open. Yeah.
Full power is even quicker, right?
Yeah, it's much quicker.
So you can do it like in a minute and be going, right?
Yeah, I think it was 120 or something like that. I stopped it one time.
It depends also on the pump hose. Now I saw the filters and everything is back flashing.
So I think we have not so much pressure like when the system is not in use.
But you see it's three and a half thousand liters and it goes very quick.
Now this part is completely full. Now you can see it later here.
I think in 10 seconds the level comes up.
Always when we don't use the connection points, close them.
Always close, yeah.
Like this because you have here rubber rings also here.
And when they are in the sun, they get damaged.
They get damaged, makes sense.
Now you see how it starts shaking?
Yeah.
That is because of the amount of water coming inside.
The tank is getting full and it's shaking.
Now you see now the level.
Yep.
Now it goes up.
How many liters is a full tank?
Three and a half thousand.
So it's a lot.
It's a lot.
How much is a Jopper that we have?
I don't know exactly.
Do you know how much it's inside the Jopper?
Three thousand.
Okay, so then we have six and a half thousand liters.
So it's also possible to go with both vehicles.
First the fire truck and directly behind the truck door.
And the Jopper also have an out-touch system.
There's a gasolina pump and also we have hoses there.
And also the fire gun so we can use both machines separately.
Now you can see we are coming up and up and up.
Now you see the good thing is from the water the black parts looking different.
Like behind because now you can see easy how full it is.
Ah yes.
Steph start a little bit closing, not too much.
So once it's getting like almost you start closing right?
Yeah.
There is not a problem to overfill because we have a big hole in the roof.
And there the water comes out when it's too full.
Okay, so there's no problem.
It's nice to see when it goes up that we slowly start going off.
Great.
So no potential of catastrophe from overfill.
Yeah.
It's good.
Is there any down-touch to having the top open?
Like anything going inside?
No.
Because this is special, yeah close.
This is special filtered water.
It's not prepared with claw or something like the drink water.
But it's filtered water.
All the points we have different points here on the land.
I think they are not all connected because the AgriElectrica didn't do that.
But for the future we will go forward to have different points on all the technical walls we have here around.
Later we have points where we can connect the hose to suck water for the tank.
Yes.
One of these big hoses is always inside the truck.
So when we are on the road in the land area we can stop in every place and fill it there.
Yes.
When everything is already installed.
So now we close it again.
Then we can remove the connection.
Only the hose put down.
This we put here.
Important close again.
Also important because of somebody who's playing.
When somebody opens it here or here without engine it's also leaking.
Because the tank is full and with 3,500 liters.
So this is the closed position right?
It's opposite to the direction.
Yes.
That is always the closed position.
Exactly.
When you open and it looks like that.
Okay.
So now we go back in.
Yep.
And then we go and empty the truck.